so Angela talked a little bit about the
do you have any memories of a special
conversation or or something about
movies that you felt like there was
something special about his insight into
them or could you describe a little bit
about what you felt made his interest so
unique well he certainly saw all the
movies you know he had an incredible
memory for remembering performances and
most individual actors who and he would
talk about them and and talk about his
reaction to their work and so on
he was extremely knowledgeable about the
business and when you think about his
how he began he was a young actor
actually as we know and he never really
pursued an actor's life he became an
observer of other actors which was so
interesting which he was brilliant at he
he could talk about and describe a
performance better than anybody I ever
knew and I loved just listening to him
talk about performances and and shows
that he'd seen and movies that he loved
and he was a man of our business and you
know there weren't too many of them and
we've treasured those people because
they were aware of the works that we as
actors put into our shows and our movies
our theatre whatever it is and he
understood it totally he was right there
in the middle and I love that about him
he was he was just terrific
I miss him today
you know what I I've thought was
wonderful about Bob - I'm sure you were
with him when people came up you know
people came up and they were dead to
talk to him and when he was talking to
you it was if if you were the only
person that existed I never saw Bob if
if we were together and somebody came up
and said oh tell me about something he
gave his whole attention to them he
never turned to me as hit a Carol I'll
be right with you it was none of that I
thought that was a rather remarkable
trait because people were pulling at him
and asking the happiest day of his life
he called me one day we're gonna have
champagne because well I don't work a
computer so you people will know this
I'm still with Penn and he couldn't
quill but I'm not kidding but he called
me and said Siri and Alexa made three
mistakes so we had you know who those
tramps are don't you that's what he
called them I'm not kidding